اجازه مدفوعه الاجر لمده 30 يوما للازواج
الجدد منحه جديده تقدمها بعض الاقاليم في
الصين تحفيزا للانجاب بعد تراجع عدد سكان
الصين وانخفاض معدل المواليد خلال العام
الماضي يعتقد بان تمديد اجازه الزواج هو
احد الطرق الفعاله لزياده معدل الخصوبه في
ظل دعوات باقرار مجموعه من السياسات
الاخرى التي تدعم الانجاب بما في ذلك
اجازه الابو والمدفوعه تاتي هذه الاجازه
بعد ان فرضت الصين سياسه الطفل الواحد منذ
عام 80 الى 2015 وفشلت في تحقيق النمو
السكاني المطلوب بعدما شجعت المتزوجين على
انجاب اكثر من طفل
[موسيقى]
يعني اجازه مدفوعه ل 30 يوم ليقعدوا
الازواج بوجه بعض رح يرجعوا بعد شهر بوراق
الطلاق على الشغل انا مش فاهم المنطق انه
يخلوا الناس يحبوا بعض في خلوهم قاعدين
بخلقه بعض كل الوقت بس ما حدا بيعطي اجازه
زواج 30 30 يوم 30 يوم كثير شهر كثير يعني
كثير على اللي مقبلين على الزواج واللي
متزوجين جديد واكيد على المتزوجين صار لهم
زمان